on va chanter c'est noël car c'est noël
à la page 25
quel
cette flamme 10
[Musique]
on
l'attendait
c'est
à vis du soap heures du mans veut
[Musique]
robin aux enfants disparus
aux bizots 110 ray
c'est
[Musique]
yannick à tous comme un slogan si
d'aurillac
[Musique]
on n'a pas le niveau pour sa part
v - garder son casino
[Musique]
l'aide des gitanes pour toi aubry
démenti
peuple soit sorti les
pouvoir
naissances répondu guy collet
c'est l'idée et pas pleuvoir des
chanteurs
nous venons
les tours espérant dit
comme ça
c'est noël
le tout espérant 10
[Musique]
biya
non
rihanna
[Musique]
ou
encore de sang dans une autre
[Musique]
et c'est ça il
a ajouté qu tétouan
m
[Musique]
magillem
hélas un train chaleur 6e des bois
l'enfoiré dans ces
contrées on adore on dit
[Musique]
l'eau
une toutes espèrent en dix mois
[Musique]